The stereotype that men are smarter than women has a long history,
But in a gender battle, who actually has superior thought when it comes to it?
Are boys smarter than girls?
Early studies show that male brains are larger than 8 to 13 percent in size of female brains,
But this is due to differences in body size.
Women's brains have more saturation or flexibility, and as a result,
Larger cortical surface area.
Besides, the bigger is not always the best.
Amber whales, elephants and dolphins have larger brains than humans,
Though smart, their cognitive abilities are less than ours
But there are other structural differences
Such as having more male contacts within the hemispheres
While women have more communication between hemispheres
But overall, MRI imaging shows a significant overlap in the physical structure of the sexes.
After 1400 study of brains and gender comparison,
The researchers found that most men and women show up
A mosaic of typical structures between females and males in the brain
The study also assessed gender stereotyping.
Such as how video games are often considered to be male behavior while scrapbooking female behavior
The study found that only 0.1 of the test subjects showed only the typical behavior of males and females
IQ tests find results of similar major studies showing little intelligence
Or there are no gender differences in general intelligence
But women have stronger verbal abilities, while men have more powerful visual-spatial abilities.
Interestingly, studies show more male variation in tests with their scores both worse and better.
A meta-analysis found that one in 22 studies showed that men had an IQ of 3.3 to 5.5 higher than women
But this study was questioned by academics who found a flawed methodology
In the academic performance of language, mathematics and science,
Women consistently received a better score in 70% of nations.
But in the SAT-SAT tests in the United States, men scored 33 points higher in math and science.
Other tests, such as the International Student Assessment Program, have shown that both sexes perform equally well
In many countries, girls have performed better, such as Iceland, indicating cultural and environmental differences
And do not necessarily play biological differences
However, research has found that stereotypes about women's performance are already affecting their success
When it is said that a particular test in mathematics is of great importance in gender differences,
Women performed much worse than their male counterparts.
While women who were told there was no difference, they scored the same score
This phenomenon is known as the typical threat.
So Google search data shows that parents 2.5 times more likely to
To search Is my son talented? More than is my daughter talented?
Despite 11% of girls in the gifted programs in America.
The girls picked up this bias as early as 6 years of age.
When the story of the fifth-year-old was told about a really intelligent person
Both boys and girls connect intelligence with gender
But at the age of 6 both girls and boys chose a male character as the smartest.
In a similar experience children were asked if they wanted to play a game for people who are really smart
Again at the age of five both sexes wanted to play the game, but before the age of six the girls decided that these games were not for them
Although women strive to work in the fields of science, technology and mathematics, studies show they face barriers
In the study of double blindness in the Faculty of Science from the universities of scientific research, applications for the position of Laboratory Director were classified
What they did not know was that the request for appointment was made randomly either male or female names
What they do not know is that requests are randomly assigned either to male or female names
As a result, faculty members considered male applicants to be more efficient
Are eligible for guidance, although applications with women's names are identical
Higher male salaries have been offered from 30,000 to 26,000 for females
Although these studies produce a realistic fact that points to increasing parallels
Gender as decades go by and education
Despite these barriers, women continue to contribute to our collective scientific knowledge
Rosalind Franklin has allowed us to understand our DNA
Katherine Johnson assisted Apollo 11 landing on the moon
This year Maryam Mirzakhani is the first woman to win the Nobel Prize for Mathematics
Said fellow mathematician Isabella Lappa
Nothing persuades me just like Mirzakhani's choice that a woman is capable of doing
Sports research at the same level as men
I had no doubt about it in the first place
What he does instead is that we as a society, men and women alike, have become better at encouraging
Nurturing sports talent in women, and more capable of recognizing excellence in women's work
To learn more we asked ASPA Women's Science to speak personally about their experiences that have grown
Giving insight into how to navigate the societal pressures of being a woman.
Click the screen or link in the description to check that video
And subscribe to weekly science videos every Thursday.
Channel translation: mohamed ramzy